buongiorno e grazie allora avevo
forse un certo modo in realtà dopo
l'ultimo video abbastanza
raccapricciante secondo me devo cambiare
un po di direzioni io mi occupo di
cervello mi occupi cervello e cervello è
una connessione globale di
approssimativamente 100 miliardi di
neuroni che si collegano tra di loro ma
si collegano in maniera non fissa perché
le connessioni sono dinamiche c'è se non
mi serve devo risparmiare energia
this connetto quella cellula e mi
riconnetta un'altra però un'altra
funzione e cervello vuol dire tutto
quello che siamo
tutto quello che siamo perché il
cervello vuol dire muoversi vuol dire
mangiare vuol dire emotività creatività
astrazione e tutto quello che noi
possiamo realizzare nelle nostre
meravigliose vite ma
cervello vuol dire anche un sistema
intelligente
fortunatamente che si rapporta con
l'esterno io sono qualcosa perché ho
modello interno che si connette a un
modello esterno e questo soprattutto
grazie a una funzione che è quella della
decodifica dei segnali ce ne arriva uno
stimolo
lo faccio mio e creo per rendere più
semplice il il discorso che faccio un
esempio la musica la musica è uno
strumento quindi un l'onta sisic a che
arriva a me io la trans buco tramite
l'orecchio la trasformò in un segnale
elettrochimico che va a diffondersi
all'interno del cervello in questa
diffusione io sono in grado di capire
per convenzione spesso se quello è un
violino o un contrabbasso un pianoforte
se la nota che sto ascoltando è un do re
on me se è singola o se all'interno di
un orchestra quello che la musica genere
emozionalmente su di me non solo ma a
questo punto tutte le reazioni che
questa genesi emozionale innesca posso
ballare posso piangere
posso ridere posso far viaggiare i
ricordi posso sognare
posso inventare posso fare qualsiasi
cosa per cui da un segnale fisico
arriviamo a un'idea che è la capacità di
astrazione che probabilmente la più alta
il più alto livello di attività del
nostro cervello
le connessioni semplificano o perlomeno
dovrebbero aiutare no tutti questi
sistemi di comunicazione abbiamo
lavorato negli anni passati sui
musicisti perché il cervello del
musicista è diverso homo anatomicamente
parlando è diverso e abbiamo fatto degli
esperimenti intanto abbiamo visto che
per esempio le aree acustiche possono
andare attivare le aree motorie cioè ti
faccio sentina musica e vado attivare la
le motoria cosa strana ma fu preso un
quartetto d'archi e lì fu fatta solare
una partitura registrando i loro
elettroencefalogrammi stessa operazione
fu fatta facendogli riascoltare la loro
esecuzione
la cosa sorprendente era che le loro
attività cerebrali si sincronizza vano
in maniera fantastica durante
l'esecuzione quindi erano un tutt'uno
una connessione ma la stessa cosa
avveniva nel momento in cui si ri
ascoltavano siri sincronizza vano
un'altra volta
ovviamente la domanda che viene in tutto
questo sistema complesso chi è che
comanda è facilmente intuibile che la
sfera emotiva soverchia tutti perché è
perché decide perché decide perché noi
viviamo in funzione delle nostre
emozioni non potrebbe essere
diversamente
ancora per poco probabilmente però è
quella che comanda
guardando quotidianamente tutta una
serie di indagini fotografie che noi
facciamo i nostri poveri paziente
fotografia cerebrale quindi le risonanze
le tac
mi sono sempre chiesto del perché c'è
una parte del cervello che non si ammala
mai mai o quasi
e questa struttura si chiama amigdala
che è una nocciolina una mandorla dalla
dal greco che è posta dietro nei lobi
temporali
allora ovviamente per non ammalarsi mai
deve essere veramente potenza e deve
servire veramente adatto a che cosa
serve l'amigdala l'amigdala e il sistema
limbico al quale appartiene non è solo
dell'uomo ovviamente presente in diverse
specie viventi e si occupa delle
reazioni di base quelli di emergenza
la lotta la fuga l'istinto di
conservazione della specie tramite la
riproduzione e quindi genera le risposte
primarie non solo ma interviene
ovviamente nei nei processi di
maturazione emotiva del bambino fino a
diventare uno strumento fantastico
perché per esempio è stato visto che
l'amigdala è in grado di
sincronizzandosi con gli occhi se noi
abbiamo un interlocutore in 100
millisecondi decidere a torto ragione se
chi ci sta di fronte
è una persona dalla quale ci possiamo
fidare o meno quindi è uno è uno scanner
velocissimo ma un altro problema chi ha
potere decisionale perchè può essere uno
switch cioè se decide di scattare
proiettando sacco di altre parti del
cervello innesca nelle risposte alle
quali noi non ci possiamo opporre
ritorneremo su questo dopo questa la
lascio perché bella voi ne parleremo
dopo ovviamente questa migdal a
in qualche modo comanda la nostra vita è
l'hard disk emozionale quindi la sede
delle emozioni e dell hard disk
emozionale c'è tutto quello che ci passa
dalla nostra vita a livello emotivo
viene stoccato e conservato nella micro
anche le le cose vecchissime addirittura
qualcuno dice anche quelle di ipotetiche
vite precedenti
non voglio entrare in questo campo però
vi dico se avete la possibilità di fare
un'esperienza di ipnosi regressiva
fatela perché è devastante
allora giochiamo la attimino lo facciamo
il dem brown della situazione che va
tanto di moda
facciamo finta che non viene dal greco
ma viene dall'ebraico a malta ma che
dalle marche dalla paga maria maddalena
il graal e tutt uno
allora ben brown la messa sotto la
piramide del louvre dove la sto mettendo
il graal nella teca cranica di ognuno di
noi
per farvi capire quanto è importante è
in realtà che c'è più di importante
delle emozioni
e ovvio che non siete ammalare mai vi
racconto un po di aneddoti clinici entra
in ambulatorio un paziente paraplegico
perso l'uso delle gambe totale allora lo
studio empatia emotività e decido li
propongo di fare un training sulle
schede dolore skeleton robot nel quale
uno viene inserito e cammina e li dico
guarda questo serve per mantenere i tuoi
muscoli allenati per l'apparato
cardiovascolare la piscina l'intestino
lo metto su out reining dix sedute e poi
gli chiedo allora che ne pensi
lo dice sì tutto quello che mi dicevi è
giusto ma la cosa più del mondo e
che io entro nella tua stanza e ti
guardo negli occhi mentre parco che per
me è il 90 per cento delle barriere
della mia vita
cioè io padellato completamente perché
potere decisionale ho detto oh poverino
non cammina lo faccio a camminare no era
lo stesso da gustare allo stesso livello
paziente in stato vegetativo
quindi coma profondo ogni tanto fa delle
crisi vegetative quindi aumenta la
frequenza respiratoria cardiaca
sudorazione bla bla bla bla che noi
spendiamo col farmaco quando poi a
distanza di anni ho iniziato a leggere
di queste cose di queste di questa
principessa
mi sono chiesto ma se quelle invece era
una risposta a questo è prigioniero ad
un corpo male amigdale sue intatte cioè
cervello devastato male migdal risultate
e se quella fosse la sua risposta alla
mia faccia del lunedì sfamata o alla mia
faccia contenta perché magari ho
comprato la chitarra nuova o non lo so
io che faccio gliela spengo
allora dobbiamo iniziare a ragionare un
attimino e chiediamo aiuto alla
tecnologia che ci sia la possibilità di
interpretare meglio questi segnali
perché rischiamo veramente di fare delle
cappellate imperiali per cui
entra il nostro paziente e tra l'altro
paziente danno del lobo temporale
bisogna l'amigdala amico allentata si fa
tutto il suo percorso riabilitativo
riacquista all 85 per cento delle
funzioni motorie completamente il
problema del linguaggio non risolve
colloquio diceva allora tu il mio
problema è la lentezza
in che senso nel senso che io ci metto
un sacco di tempo per fare le cose
a un certo punto il buio mio dieci
minuti di imbarazzato silenzio perché mi
passa un film ha davanti
stavo leggendo quel periodo un libro sul
qui e ora e su come noi buttiamo
praticamente via il 95 per cento del
nostro tempo non avendo assolutamente
consapevolezza di quello che facciamo
poi vi darò l'esempio per cui in realtà
quello che fa questo paziente è quello
di essere presente a ogni sua situazione
e cerco di fargli capire che il suo
danno neurologico
paradossalmente è un bene e lui mi dice
ma nel senso che sta prende in giro e
gli faccio questo esempio
quante volte tu in una giornata passi da
una porta tante quante volte tu ti rendi
conto che stai attraversando la porta
mai
passiamo se una situazione un po più
conversazione
io parlo con lei o meglio lei parla con
me prima che le finisce di parlare io
già rispondo quindi vuol dire non la sto
ascoltando in realtà c'è però so già
tutto un serio campionario di risposte
stereotipate che inserisco nella
conversazione quindi a realta non me ne
frega niente quello che mi state dicendo
lei
provate a fare un esercizio prendete un
atto banale della vostra vita aprire la
porta a lavarsi i denti rilassare i
muscoli del collo quello che volete
provate nel momento in cui apriamo la
porta a dire sono presente sono qui sto
aprendo la porta a fine giornata ha
contate quante volte siete riusciti a
fare questa cosa su 100 volte forse
cinque forse anche volendo poi ci si
allena si diventa bravi è un certo punto
inizierete a scoprire il suono della
porta la pesantezza della porta
la resistenza che la porta fa al
movimento non vi dico che cosa può
succedere quando iniziate applicare
questa cosa alle conversazioni
scoprirete che siete nati
paradossalmente siete nati che gli altri
hanno qualcosa da dirvi e scoprirete che
dalla maggior parte delle persone non ve
ne frega niente quindi inizierete a
ridare un senso a quello che fate è un
giochino strano però è così ma noi
ovviamente oltre aver perso la
consapevolezza ci dobbiamo complicare la
vita e ci inventiamo il mondo virtuale
ora cesa un sacco di persone che mi
ammazzerebbero in questo momento però e
mi ricordo una cosa concerto de lollis
top 50 mila persone
una botta di suolo colori l'energia di
questi c'è una roba fantastica 50.000
persone 48 mila saranno state col
telefonino così
perché il problema non è guardare il
concerto e godere il problema è fare un
video che non vedrò mai perché fa schifo
ma lo devo condividere sui social perché
devo dimostrare al mondo che io sono qui
e ora a vedere il concerto dei rolling
stone attraverso il video secondo me
follia ma è possibile pure che io stia
criticando questa cosa ma in realtà
questa cosa è un aspetto evolutivo già
ci stiamo piegando uscito un articolo di
science cui gli adolescenti stanno
piegando il collo per stare sui tablet o
che il mondo andrà visto attraverso i
telefonini fatemi scende prima per
favore velo perché ora non la reggo
stato l'amore no l'amore non è il caso a
bellissimo calcola l'amore avete
presente quella cosa che quando girate
l'angolo incontrate gli angoli più belli
gli occhi più belli dell'universo che vi
raccontare una frazione di secondo il
segreto del cosmo no sempre meno sempre
meno perché le storie oggi non esistono
le storie non iniziano e non finiscono
noi siamo in un iter presente continuo
che non serve a nessuno ma le storie
d'amore sono regolate dai campi di
ricezione dei cellulari e dall'ansia di
spunta
e fondamentalmente siccome non finiscono
alle storie d'amore e li manteniamo in
questo limbo fondamentale come le
regoliamo con gli smile i cuoricini le
foto inoltrate se so carine e se
facciamo un'analisi se qualcuno di voi è
una cosa di questo tipo ma secondo me in
parecchi possiamo cronometrare cioè noi
sappiamo che ogni 48 ore ci arriverà il
cuoricino come un automatismo ta ta ta
ta
noi siamo assolutamente fatti così in
questo momento canova era bello assai
questo ancora più bella
io credo che nonostante tutto
qual è l'idea del set non è un'idea è un
invito a ritornare uomini a ritrovare
l'umanità l'emozionalità ce la stiamo
giocando
noi siamo non connessi noi siamo
connettibili oggi è diverso la
connessione è un'altra cosa cioè i
nostri cervelli utilizzano le
commissioni ma noi umanamente non siamo
connessi
provate a pensarci quindi forse ho fatto
un passo indietro va recuperata quella
cosa meravigliosa che si ama umanità per
ri apprezzare la bellezza per
riapprezzare un tramonto e perché noi
abbiamo il maledetto o benedetto diritto
dovere di poterci ancora innamorare di
tutto e provare a dare un senso a
un'ipotetica esistenza di dio
grazie
[Applauso]